teils schiff teils kraftwerk
jasin b startet zur jungfernfahrt
sie bringt elektrizität auf eine kleine
indonesische insel
es ist ein balanceakt der mut
[Musik]
extreme kraft aufwendungen
und blitzschnelle reaktionen erfordert
nothalt nothalt
die snb ist kein normales schiff
modernste technologie macht sie zu einem
riesigen schwimmenden generator
als sogenanntes kraftwerks schiff läuft
sie länder an die eine zuverlässige
stromversorgung brauchen
[Musik]
der typische konzern power ship ist der
einzige weltweit der eine power schiff
leute anbietet
starten
steuerbord
15 18 die jasin bailly ist eines seiner
neuesten kraftwerks schiffe
sie ist tun das war 1 60 meter lang 1
und 20 meter breit und tragt 55 meter
über die wasserlinie
bald wird sie zu ihrem ersten einsatz
auslaufen
[Musik]
das schiff begibt sich auf eine
vierwöchige reise von istanbul aus wird
es nach westen ins mittelmeer fahren und
dann richtung süden um den suezkanal zu
passieren
danach wird die jasin bay das rote meer
und den indischen ozean überqueren um
die indonesische insel am boden an zu
laufen wie es für die nächsten fünf
jahre mit strom versorgen soll
doch im moment hat die yasin b probleme
sie sollte heute getauft werden
stattdessen wird sie zur werft
geschleppt sie liegt nicht einmal gerade
im wasser
hier darf niemand durch
[Musik]
sobald das schiff am dock lied muss es
schnell gehen die schwachstelle wird im
ballastwasser system vermutet
[Musik]
bevor die jasin bay zum kraftwerk schiff
wurde war sie ein schwergutfrachter mit
zwei leistungsstarken kränen auf der
backbordseite
als gegengewicht zu den hub lasten der
kräne wurden zwei tanks auf der
steuerbordseite mit beton gefüllt
[Musik]
um deren gewicht auszugleichen müssen
die tanks auf der backbordseite mit
seewasser sogenannten ballastwasser
gefüllt werden über rohre wird das
seewasser in die verbleibenden acht
ballasttanks des schiffs geleitet
allerdings legt eine leitung in einem
der beton gefüllten tanks weshalb das
schiff nicht austariert werden kann
[Musik]
arbeiter der schiffswerft kriechen tief
in den sumpf zufall liegenden teil der
ballast leitung doch anders weg kommen
sie nicht heran denn das liegt inmitten
des betons
wären sie mich ist die mannschaft unten
um eine schnelle lösung zu finden musste
sogar der konstrukteur des schiffes am
rücken
das ist eine wichtige leitung in einem
wichtigen system wir müssen das leck
reparieren
[Musik]
wie sieht's aus ist das fertig dieser
abschnitt ist erledigt ok weiter so er
plant die alte rohrleitungen komplett zu
ersetzen
[Musik]
die enden der alten leitung werden
verschlossen um das leck zu isolieren
dann wird eine neue 25 meter lange röhre
direkt über den betonblock verlegt diese
ausweich leitung lässt das wasser wieder
von einem tag zum nächsten fließen
das macht uns zu schaffen die
reparaturkosten spielen keine rolle nur
die zeit
die mannschaft liegt bereits hinter dem
zeitplan zurück
jeder verlorene tag wird heute
verlorenes geld in der kunde zahlt erst
wenn das kraftwerk schiff erfolgreich
ans netz angeschlossen wurde und strom
liefert
13.000 kilometer entfernt auf der
indonesischen insel ambon stößt das
örtliche stromnetz täglich an seine
grenzen die menschen hier können die
ankunft der snb kaum erwarten so auch
harry potter
[Musik]
ich bin auf am bonn geboren und
aufgewachsen
es gab ja schon immer viele
stromausfälle seit meiner kindheit
so hatte leitet auf amborn einen
vertrieb für tiefkühlfisch
wie die meisten betriebe und haushalte
der 400.000 einwohner insel ist auch
seine firma auf diesel oder gas
generatoren angewiesen wenn das örtliche
stromnetz aus doch das ist teuer nun
soll die jasin bay helfen kosten und
ärger zu vermeiden
[Musik]
zurück zur schiffswerft in der türkei
hier haben sich 24 stunden arbeit auf
engstem raum ausgezahlt die
überbrückungs leitung ist fertiggestellt
[Musik]
es ist gut ausgegangen das war auch
nötig
das schiff kann auslaufen kapitän david
karatas trifft die letzten
vorbereitungen dass mir erst ruhig das
wäre das gut
ich hoffe es bleibt die ganze fahrt über
so
[Applaus]
nach einer kurzen taufzeremonie verlässt
jasin bei den 4
[Applaus]
geschwindigkeit 1,3
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bevor sie in see sticht muss sie wie
jedes neue oder umgebaute schiff ihre
seetauglichkeit beweisen und einige
manöver absolvieren
denn
der erste test schafe richtungswechsel
[Musik]
hart backbord
nach einem kurswechsel nach steuerbord
lässt kapitän caracas nach backbord
reden hart backbord
plötzlich neigt sich die gassen bailly
stark nach steuerbord
kapitän karatas weist den steuermann an
das schiff auszurichten
damit chefs mit chips doch nichts
geschieht
es fühlt sich an als könnte das ganze
schiff jeden moment kennt
die erste testfahrt der jas de läuft
alles andere als glatt beim
richtungswechsel neigt sich das
kraftwerk schiff gefährlich zur seite
alles was nicht befestigt wurde rutscht
auf die steuerbordseite des schiffs in
der kombüse gehört das geschirr in
steuerbar 20
der kapitän da wo keiner tasche bleibt
die ruhe selbst steuerbar steuerbord was
man ebook oder funktionieren der
erfahrene kapitän weiß seine mittel zu
nutzen
broder fall steuerbare steigert um sein
schiff so schnell wie möglich
aufzurichten rudolf matter
[Musik]
nach einigen minuten ist das geschafft
oder mit schiffs
für den schiffs kellner ok caracas
fühlte es sich an wie eine ewigkeit
ich hatte angst weil ich nicht wusste
was los war das stand so
etliche teller und gläser sind auf den
boden geschmettert
das brückenteam muss herausfinden was
schief gelaufen ist
es hat sich stärker geneigt als erwartet
jedes schiff neigt sich bei einem
richtungswechsel nach außen es handelt
sich um die sogenannte kränkung
doch drei faktoren verschärfen diese
situation
erstens ihre hohen aufbauten und kräne
machen die gassen bay kopflastig
zweitens da die treibstoff- und
ballasttanks nicht gänzlich gefüllt sind
liegt der snb hoch und leicht im wasser
doch die steuerbord tanks sind mit beton
gefüllt
das führte dazu dass die jasin bay
doppelt so stark kränkte wie vor sehen
wenn wir hart nach backbord einschlagen
erwarten wir höchstens zehn grad neigung
[Musik]
deshalb werden probefahrten absolviert
um zu sehen wie sich das schiff verhält
wir waren überrascht sie hat sich über
20 grad geneigt
das schiff schwimmt wieder aufrecht
kapitän caracas und sein erster offizier
lassen einen plan sie wollen für die
fahrt nach indonesien weit mehr ballast
aufnehmen
sie werden alle acht ballasttanks mit
seewasser und 800 tonnen zusätzlichem
schwerin auffüllen das wird den
schwerpunkt des schiffs senken und den
rumpf ausbalancieren damit die nächsten
richtungswechsel weniger dramatisch
verlaufen
[Musik]
wir senken unseren schwerpunkt damit das
schiff nicht so stark gesenkt
es wird dadurch stabiler wenn der wind
von backbord oder steuerbord weg dürfen
wir uns nicht zu stark steigen
während das schiff von einem bunker bot
betankt wird kümmert sich die kombüsen
crew um die versorgung der besatzung es
essen muss für die kommenden zwei monate
reichen in den frühen morgenstunden des
zweiten tages ist das schiff voll
bestückt und bereit seine reise
anzutreten
endlich läuft die gassen bay mit ihrer
20 mann starken besatzung in richtung
indonesien aus
[Musik]
nach mehreren stunden nähert sich das
schiff den dardanellen der einzigen
verbindung zu ermitteln wo an der
zufahrt staut sich der verkehr
[Musik]
mehr als 20 oder 30 schiffe warten alle
schiffe gen süden müssen abwarten bis
ein riesiger erdgas tanker in nördlicher
richtung passiert ist der tanker ist
sehr groß und er befördert gefahrgut
[Musik]
wegen seiner explosiven fracht dürfen
andere schiffe erst in die 61 kilometer
lange meerenge einfahren wenn der tanker
sie verlassen hat
die dann allen sind für alle schiffe
gespart
wir müssen mindestens noch sechs sieben
stunden warten
es ist eine unerwartete verzögerung
gleich zu beginn der reise kapitän
caracas und sein erster maschinist
versuchen per telefon einen platz weiter
vorne in der schlange zu ergattern wir
befinden uns 28 seemeilen vor tanaka
andernfalls könnten sie ihren geplanten
konvoi durch den suezkanal verpassen
den konvoi verpassen verliert unsere
firma geld rund
150000 dollar pro tag
die anrufer zahlen sich aus als der
erdgas tanker aus der meerenge ausfährt
rückt die ja in der warteschlange vor
und der kapitän spart fünf stunden ein
bruder
wirtschaftschefs 195 mit chefs
innerhalb von drei stunden passiert die
jasin bay die meerenge
von da aus geht es durch den suezkanal
und schließlich über den indischen ozean
25 tage später nähert sich das schiff
seinem ziel der insel ambon
[Musik]
vor der küste ist bereits ein
spezialisiertes anker team im einsatz
sie müssen einen rostigen lastkahn auf
position ziehen bevor das kraftwerk
schiff eintrifft
allerdings hat ihr schlepper mit dem
kann so seine mühe
wir versuchen das ding zu schleppen
kapitän arda arman leitet den einsatz
als erstes muss er 16 massive
betonblöcke an vier stellen im meer
versenken
der motor dieses schleppers ist sehr
schwach
kapitän was soll ich tun der frachtkahn
muss umgehend auf position gebracht
werden die betonblöcke sind die
vorläufigen ankerpunkte und das
kraftwerk schiff fest zu machen
es ist ammanns aufgabe das kraftwerk
schiff yasin b sicher zu verankern damit
es an das örtliche stromnetz
angeschlossen werden werden doch alles
hängt davon ab ob die marode ausrüstung
mitspielt
[Musik]
während die gassen bay die insel umfährt
bereitet kapitän ermahnen 700 meter vor
der ostküste die aufwändige verankerung
vor
allerdings ist sein schlepper alles
andere als modern
backbord backbord
halten
sein anker system soll das kraftwerk
schiff fünf jahre lang sicher auf
position halten
wir fahren hier ein art steuerbord und
backbord aus
im moment ringt ammann
doch mit dem widerspenstigen lastkahn
noch ein meter
der lastkahn hat 16 massive betonblöcke
geladen die an vier positionen im meer
versenkt werden soll doch zuerst muss er
an ort und stelle manövriert werden
steuerbord aus steuerbord aus weiter
voraus anker werfen endlich schiebt der
frontlader den ersten 17 tonnen birk vom
deck
[Musik]
das ist eine schwierige position
fahren wir näher an das ist leicht
gesagt wir können es wenigstens
versuchen okay also gut
kapitän armen kämpft noch immer mit dem
kann um seinen plan umzusetzen muss er
die mannschaft anleiten gasthaus zu la
vie len soll sein er ist auch egal wenn
er diese beiden zusammen in
grana wie tieren
und den frontlader dirigieren
[Musik]
er hilft sogar dabei eine kette zu
zerteilen für einen kapitän ungewöhnlich
nach fünf stunden in der tropischen
hitze sind die blöcke erfolgreich
versenkt
unterdessen ist das café schiff
angekommen vier wochen hat die reise
gedauert
die jasin bay wird vor der küste
verankert und dann über kabel mit einem
mast an land verbunden
von dort fließt der strom 2,5 kilometer
ins landesinnere zu einer trafostation
die an das stromnetz der insel
angeschlossen ist
[Musik]
am nächsten tag kommt das wichtigste
werkzeug in kapitän ammanns arsenal an
das riesige leistungsstarke
hochseeschlepper schifffahrt schultern
der 75 meter lange schleppe wird buch am
heck mit dem kraftwerk schiff verteilt
[Musik]
ammann leitet den einsatz vom schlepper
aus während kapitän color touch das
kraftwerk shift befehligt
wir warten auf ihr kommando
der große schlepper wird die jasin bay
200 meter vor die küste bugsieren
dort wird das kraftwerk schiff einen
seiner buchecker auf der backbordseite
werfen es wird seitwärts manövrieren
einen anker auf der steuerbordseite
werfen und sich mittig zwischen beiden
positionieren dann wird der schlepper
das schiff rückwärts schieben und es
wird einen dritten anker vom heck werfen
doch die uncle genügend licht und das
schiff auf position zu halten die
mannschaft muss zusätzlich zu spannen
zwischen dem schiff und in vier
betonblock positionen unter wasser sowie
3000 zur küste
stahlrute ausstrahle aus
den bug zum wind gedreht tastet sich die
gassen bay gemeinsam mit dem schlepper
langsam die küste entging
sie wirft ihren backbord anker dann den
steuerbord anker dann drehen wir sie
[Musik]
das kraftwerk schiff wirft einen anker
von der backbordseite
um den steuerbord anker zu werfen
bewegen wir uns mit beiden schiffen
seitwärts wie krebse
das paar kämpft sich seitwärts gegen den
wind vor ist die yasin b ihren
steuerbord anker werfen kann
um sich dann mittig zwischen den ankern
zu positionieren setzt die mannschaft
die buchbinder auf der backbordseite 1
mit ihr wird die ankerkette eingeholt
und das schiff seitwärts bewegt doch
plötzlich bleibt die winde stehen
unsere backbord wenig kennt wir können
sie nicht mehr einsetzen
[Musik]
ihr hebel hat sich verklemmt die kette
rührt sich nicht mehr und es kommt noch
schlimmer
[Musik]
die dichtung ist gebrochen überlässt
die verklemmte winde hat erschütterungen
im darunter gelegenen pumpen raum
verursacht
dadurch wurde eine dichtung des
hydraulik systems beschädigt
hydraulikflüssigkeit tritt aus und
überschwemmt den pumpen raum
pumpen und wände sind ausgeschaltet wir
müssen das manöver unterbrechen der
erste maschine ist firat kein geld steht
unter druck ohne hydraulikflüssigkeit
können wieder pumpen noch hinten
arbeiten
während kann gail shea im heißen kumpel
raum über den reparaturen schwitzt
versucht alle dallmann weiterhin den
steuerbord anker auszuwerfen
das kraftwerk schiff schaltet in den
rückwärtsgang während der schlepper nach
kräften hilft langsam schiebt sich die
yasin b rückwärts doch dann nothalt
nothalt
notfalls nothalt
die operation kommen zum erliegen
wenn ich über funk spreche will ich
nicht sehen andere reden hören erledigt
sie sind aus die maschinen würden von
der brücke gestellt keine panik captain
armer können sie ihre position halten
vorwärts nach steuerbord
ich halte sie
können wir
nach seiner 13.000 kilometer lange reise
zur indonesischen insel ambon musters
kraftwerkschef yasin bay nur 200 meter
vor der küste einen nothalt einlegen
gehen sie zum heck auf die
steuerbordseite
nehmen sie das tau- und führen sie es
zum betonblock
ich habe gesehen dass 1000 die
schiffsschraube der ersten bei geraten
ist
beim rückwärtsfahren hat sich das tau
eines betonblocks in der schiffsschraube
des kraftwerks schiffs verfangen
es hätte sich böse verheddern können der
ausguck am hektar jasin bay hätte
kapitän david karlsch warnen müssen doch
zum glück hat schlepper kapitän arda
roman das tau rechtzeitig gesehen gutes
mit beibooten entfernen lassen
als sie man muss man schnell entscheiden
und umgehend handeln das ist das
wichtigste
mit der silbe problem nicht noch einmal
auftritt weist ammann das kraftwerk
schiff an den motor auszuschalten
langsam langsam
dann zieht der schlepper die yasin b
alleine auf position
über die nächsten drei stunden hält der
schlepper das schiff anordnung stillen
die mannschaft verteilt es von land aus
und mit den betonblöcken am meeresgrund
die arbeiten laufen bis in die nacht
ohne funktionierende bub winde auf der
backbordseite des kraftwerks schiffs
wir machen jetzt von hand
[Musik]
die decke arbeiter spannen die langen
tau mit hilfe von flaschenzügen
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen ist das schiff
endlich ausreichend verankert nun kann
es seine aufgabe in angriff nehmen
die snb wird über leitungen mit einem
mast an der küste verbunden und das
stromnetz der insel zu speisen
ein erfahrenes monteur team von der
indonesischen insel java zieht kabel
über das dick
unter der leitung von hits wie hussein
zu ab werden sie in 15 metern höhe über
den hoch gehievt um die aufbauten des
schiffes mit einem strommast an land zu
verbinden
[Musik]
dafür ist ein akrobatisches können nötig
sie sitzen auf den isolator
und tasten sich so vorsichtig vor ist
zum ende der leitungs brücke
[Musik]
danach versuchen sie so das
gleichgewicht zu halten
und die leitungs brücke zu befestigen
die leitungs brücke verbindet die
stromleitungen auf beiden seiten des
gerüsts
arif du die hertener zieht die schrauben
fest ein gefährlicher job in luftiger
höhe auch nach sieben jahren kann seiner
mutter dabei nicht zu geben
sie macht sich sorgen
wenn sie ein video sieht es mich bei der
arbeit zeigt
die freileitung monteure sind nicht die
einzigen die sich beeilen das schiff
einsatzfähig zu machen im generator raum
arbeiten 50 türkische techniker die neu
an bord gekommen sind
[Musik]
sie spülen die 69 18 megawatt
dieselgeneratoren durch um ablagerungen
zu entfernen
dann geben sie schmieröl hinein die
generatoren haben je 18 zylinder mit
riesigen kolben von je 50 cm durchmesser
bevor sie strom für amon erzeugen können
müssen die generatoren ihren ersten
anlass test vor ort bestehen zum letzten
mal wurden sie vor sechs monaten in der
fabrik getestet
[Musik]
unterdessen leitet kapitän arm an die
zweite phase der verankerung 1 er muss
die taue und schiffsanker mit einem
zusätzlichen satz von wesentlich
schwereren ankern und ketten ergänzen
alle aus dem weg
[Musik]
es gilt das schiff und seine
stromleitungen zum land auch bei
schwerstem wetter exakt auf position zu
halten
nachlassen
[Musik]
das schleppschiff wird nacheinander zehn
zusätzliche anker auslegen in jeweils
gegenläufigen fahren
[Musik]
so wird die yasin b im hafen gesichert
um für die nächsten fünf jahre das
örtliche stromnetz zu unterstützen
leider ist eine der bug winden der jasin
bay noch immer außer betrieb
ich brauche die bänder die große doch
ammanns männer haben einen plan wie sie
die erste 70 tonnen kette an bord ziehen
können
[Musik]
sie werden entführungs seien für die
ankerkette durch zwei löcher im bug
schanz kleid des kaffees schiffs führen
und dann dieses seil mit der winde des
schiffs einholen dadurch wird die kette
auf das deck der jas in bälde zu bleiben
sie mit dem schneidbrenner dort bleiben
sie dort das sei nach ok los es reicht
um das neue und die kette zu ziehen
10.10
[Musik]
die kerze wird an decke zu die arbeiter
des kraftwerks schiffs befestigen sie
jetzt kann das große schleppschiff
zurücksetzen
lösen und die kette gleitet von seinem
heck
erst als sie voll ausgelegt ist wird der
elf tonnen schwere anker geworfen
[Musik]
das ist das signal
ich habe dem kapitän versprochen zwei
anker zu werfen
einer ist erledigt jetzt kommt der
zweite
über die nächsten drei tage hält das
team sein hohes tempo der vorgang des
anker werfen es wird jeden tag an
verschiedenen punkten um das kraftwerk
schiff wiederholt die besatzung des
schleppers ist jedes mal hoch
konzentriert wenn ihr schweren ketten
vom deck rauschen
doch als der vierte tag anbricht
hat sich die kette nummer 7 mit einer
anderen verhakt wie stark die winde der
ja in wehr auch zieht die schweren
kettenglieder bewegen sich nicht
[Musik]
die männer auf dem schlepper wollen
weitermachen
[Musik]
und offenbar ist der erste offizier
unter druck
[Musik]
die stimmung an deck ist angespannt
der erste offizier und sein team
versuchen eine schwere ankerkette über
eine andere zu ziehen
wenn der 10 bleibt sie stecken die winde
ist am limit und die decke helfer haben
kaum platz zum arbeiten jetzt ist es
wichtig ruhe zu bewahren ein fehler kann
schwere folgen haben
diese kette ist sehr schwer die kann
einen schnell umbringen
wer nicht auf die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen achtet wird
nicht nur verletzt er stört
die bleibt stecken ich brauche das geld
sei
dann eine mögliche lösung
das funktioniert
ziehen sie das haus
kurzmann ergün klettert über das
tanzkleid um die kette mit hilfe einer
schlinge zu befreien
auch der innenseite hebt einen kettenzug
die glieder an damit sie besser rutschen
es klappt jetzt kann die kette verbunden
der anker geworfen werden
das war schwierig
[Musik]
zwei tage später sind alle anker im
wasser das vertrauen ist fast
abgeschlossen 13 anker halten das schiff
nun können sich die männer
dem strom zu wenden denn das schiff der
insel liefern soll
noch sechs tage bis zum vertraglich
vereinbarten termin techniker testen die
kapazität der sechs generatoren
um zu bestehen muss jeder generator zehn
stunden lang strom ins netz einspeisen
die transformatoren vor
doch leider reicht es nicht aus einen
schalter zu betätigen der mitte strom
über die verbindungsleitungen ins netz
fließen kann
bereits im abgleich
zunächst müssen spannung und frequenz
jedes generators mit dem örtlichen
stromnetz synchronisiert werden
andernfalls können sie sich gegenseitig
aufheben und einen stromausfall
verursacht
der leitende ingenieur cancan überwacht
den abgleich im niederspannungs raum
die spannung reicht aus um einen
menschen zu töten
wenn man die sicherung entfernt muss man
darum sehr vorsichtig sein
aufgrund des hohen risikos darf dieser
test nur von fachleuten durchgeführt
werden
wenn es diskrepanzen bezüglich frequenz
oder ladung gibt können funken auftreten
doch das blinkende rote nichts
signalisiert test bestanden
sie sind synchronisiert
die yasin b kann mit der einspeisung
beginnen
nummer 1 starten
[Musik]
der generator nummer eins produziert
jetzt ein megawatt strom
seine leistung wird stufenweise auf bis
zu 15 megawatt erhöht
[Musik]
schwierig wird es wenn wir uns der
volllast nähern wann könnte es einen
überhitzung salaam geben ich hoffe nicht
das schiff wird von den örtlichen
behörden erst freigegeben wenn es
gezeigt hat dass alle sechs generatoren
zusammen 60 megawatt liefern können
genug strom für
250.000 indonesische haushalte
eine verlässliche stromversorgung kann
für fußballs jona gar nicht schnell
genug kommen er ist kühl techniker bei
einem fischereiunternehmen auf am ball
seit 20 jahren wartet er diesel
generatoren für die vielen stromausfälle
das wichtigste ist die temperatur in der
kühlung und tiefkühlung zu halten
die plötzlichen stromausfällen bereiten
ihm viel arbeit
manchmal sind es bis zu drei pro woche
manchmal sind es zwei monate
sein chef harry potter freut sich dass
das bald ein ende hat
ich hoffe sehr
dass unser stromnetz dann keine probleme
mehr verursacht und ich nicht noch mehr
hamborns bewohner und betriebe zählen
darauf dass das kraftwerk schiff ihnen
verlässliche und erschwingliche energie
liefern wird
als stünde der verantwortliche ingenieur
nicht schon genug unter druck ist nun
mit osman ja man auch noch der
geschäftsführer angereist um die letzten
schritte zu überwachen
was haben sie damit vor ich versuche 45
minuten einzusparen wären die tests der
generatoren laufen
[Musik]
geht ein taucht team ins wasser um die
verankerung der yasin b abzuschließen
[Musik]
die tore sind gerade dabei die kette
aufzuschneiden
auf jeder seite des buchs wird eine
ankerkette mit zusätzlichem gewicht
beschwert damit sie nicht durchhängt
ich zerschneide jetzt das sei sobald ich
hoffe nachlassen lassen sie nach
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass die
gezeiten den ketten nichts anhaben
können
bei flut stehen sie unter wesentlich
mehr spannung
[Musik]
um die kette vorzubereiten schneidet der
taucher den steg aus einem der
kettenglieder heraus
[Musik]
dann wird über einen schenkel von der
zweite kette befestigt an der nb tom
bloch hängen wird
17 tonnen blogs soll die ankerkette
beschweren und verhindern dass das
schiff bei flut zu stark schwankt
[Musik]
das anhängen des betonblocks ist der
riskanteste teil dieses voraus
deshalb setzen wir zur sicherheit ein
zweiter teil 1
der alte kran ächzt und zittert
doch langsam senkt sich das beton
gewicht auf dem meeresgrund endlich ist
die verankerung komplett
[Musik]
nach fünfzehn schweißtreibenden tagen
stehen nur noch die tests der letzten
drei generatoren an
[Musik]
aber es gibt ein neues problem ein
winziger hitze sensor funktioniert nicht
[Musik]
der test von generator vier muss
unterbrochen werden bis ersatz eintrifft
[Musik]
das kraftwerk schiff yasin b liegt vor
der indonesischen insel am boden
verankert
die besatzung führt die letzten tests
durch bevor man beginnen kann strom ins
örtliche netz einzuspeisen
doch ein hitze sensor an generator 4 ist
ausgefallen und es gibt keinen ersatz an
bord die crew machte in der zeit mit den
tests der generatoren 5 und 6 weiter
wir drehen nummer sechs auf
bei generator 4 gibt es ein problem mit
den sensoren
das müssen wir beheben
am nächsten morgen trifft der ersatz
sensor per einlieferung 1
ich hoffe heute abend sind wir bei 60
megawatt
die techniker installieren den neuen
hesse sensoren
unser ziel ist es zwei maschinen
gleichzeitig laufen zu lassen wenn das
klappt sieht gut aus
wir liegen gut worden
[Musik]
eine stunde später beginnt die crew mit
dem leistungstest für generator 4
steigt
währenddessen wird die leistung bei
nummer fünf und sechs weiter gesteigert
ok
acht stunden später gute nachrichten
nach zwei anstrengenden testwochen
übersteigt die gesamtleistung der
generatoren endlich 60 megawatt
ich bin zufrieden alle sechs generatoren
funktionieren es waren lange tage aber
heute werde ich endlich gut schlafen es
war eine teamleistung die yasin b an das
stromnetz von hamborn anzuschließen ich
bin stolz ein solches schiff nach
indonesien gebracht zu haben
ich bin der kapitän
meine arbeit ist getan doch die das
schiffs beginnt erst
bei dieser mammut aufgabe war teamwork
gefragt das kraftwerk schiff wurde
angeliefert
verankert
ans netz angeschlossen und zum
stromlieferanten gemacht
das schwierigste ist der anfang danach
gibt es kein zurück mehr man muss
weitermachen bis alles fertig ist mein
erfolgsrezept ist der glaube daran dass
nichts unmöglich ist
wenn jemand anders es geschafft hat sich
dann kann ich es auch
das ganze hat nur wenige wochen gedauert
der bau eines vergleichbaren kraftwerks
an land hätte drei bis zehn jahre in
anspruch können
das ist ein tolles gefühl
unser schiff ist auf position und kann
ab sofort strom für die menschen auf am
bonn produzieren
während für die seeleute und techniker
die arbeit auf anderen kraftwerks
schiffen weitergeht bleibt die jasin gut
gesichert vor amboss küste liegt von
hier aus wird sie die inseln in den
kommenden jahren zuverlässig mit strom
versorgen
[Musik]